okay let's get now to the fight to get
rid of Robert Muller there's a really
good article about how Republicans are
planning to get rid of special
prosecutor Robert Muller in Slate with
the goal of ending the Russia
investigation most of the conversation
about getting rid of Muller is focused
around will Trump fire him or not this
Trump have the authority to fire him
does he have to direct someone else like
rod Rosenstein to fire him which of
course could trigger massive protests
would it stand up constitutionally but
we've now heard from Democratic
congressman Adam shift a shift rather
who says that Republicans are gonna go
about it the following way
Devin Nunez Republican congressman
recently said that Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General should be held in
contempt of Congress sounds tough right
from one Republican to another one Trump
crony to another why is noone s going
after sessions so hard the reason Devin
Nunez says sessions should be held in
contempt is that the Justice Department
recently refused to comply with the
subpoena from Nunez that includes
classified documents the Justice
Department said the documents are
classified it would be very risky for us
to comply with the subpoena because if
we release that classified information
it could lead to things as serious as
people dying so the idea is issue
subpoenas for classified information the
Department of Justice refuses to comply
and then you slam them for refusing to
comply and call for the removal of
someone like Rod Rosenstein Rosenstein
has said he's not going to be bullied
when it comes to trump Russia you then
have the replacement to rod Rosenstein
get in there and say hey listen this
thing's too political we're ending the
Moller investigation Moeller is fired
the other possibility is you get them to
release the classified information
through the subpoenas and then you go
after Rosenstein for releasing
classified information so this is the
tactic that they're using here more than
likely Rosenstein would refuse to
release that information republicans
would immediately call for his removal
his replacement the replacement
potentially getting rid of robert muller
in a way that is less connected to trump
fired him it's pretty transparent right
like if there's any good thing we can
find here is that I would say it's that
Devin knew NASA's behavior is so obvious
and transparent
that I would hope it's not going to go
unnoticed and actually work like Nunez
might think he's being really slick all
the time and that everything he does is
just so well planned nobody's gonna
notice the underlying intentions are
abundantly clear and I'm hoping that
prevents this from happening and I'm not
entirely clear on how Jeff sessions
would be held in contempt of Congress
because didn't hear accuse himself from
the Russia investigation altogether well
I think some of the requests don't
relate to Russia stuff so it could
conceivably be within sessions purview
to either approve or not but that you're
getting at the point here which is if
you specifically make requests related
to subject matter on which sessions is
recused then it goes to rose and
scallion and you then make Rosenstein
the target there is one fact that all of
this makes undeniably clear which is
that there's only one way to protect
Robert Muller and protect the
investigation you know what it is Pat
I'm sure you can guess hmm
think it over for a little bit vote oh
yes November that's the one way right
people voting in the midterm elections
and getting republicans out of power who
are part of the protection apparatus of
Robert Muller
or rather I'm sorry the attack apparatus
against Robert Muller is really the only
protection that we can give him and even
if we get the left to get out and vote
in November will we have a fair election
because we know Russia is already trying
to tamper with the midterms and it
doesn't seem Donald Trump is too
interested in stopping that so it is a
real uphill battle and at least
hopefully awareness of what it is that's
being done here will prevent Moeller
from being fired in this way take a
quick break discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit quick break back after this
today's program is sponsored in part by
fruit or the tor is a social forecasting
game where players come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events you open up the game on
your phone or web browser you'll see a
whole range of forecasts covering topics
across the board politics sports so much
more you wager on predictions about real
world events using food tours in game
fake currency and you earn more of this
currency every time
you make a prediction that comes true
you can show off your prediction skills
to friends improve your forecasting
ability I'm even on futur you can find
my account by clicking the link in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube and this week on futur I posed
the question will robert molars trump
russia investigation end during this
year during 2018 what do you think place
your bets and you can sign up now at
fruit or calm and start making your
forecasts on political topics and so
many other topics it's free and it's
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm